You know, honesty is often something we see as a good thing, right?
We want our friends to be honest
What do you think? Is it too exaggerated?
That outfit should be burned ...
.... because he is hot!
* stupid laughs *
We want our partners to be honest
Kelly, uhm ... I have something to tell you
Ugh, I'm so nervous!
I have never said this to anyone, but ..
...I love you!
Oh my God, Anna, are you serious !? - Yes!
Omg, thank you! I do not love you.
but .... you are a nice girl!
...Okay...
But sometimes when people are honest, that comes across as hard.
I was at a friend's dinner when someone said to me:
Anna, you shouldn't get too drunk! You are noisy when you are drunk and I don't want to have to move.
And I mean, she was right, when I get drunk, I am very loud
Speaking to me, I believe most are ...
... but it felt so mean at the time. Even while I knew she wasn't trying to hurt me.
Because I was so; what should i say now?
You know how did I have to respond?
There was no way to continue the evening without keeping my mouth shut, sitting still, and feeling that I wasn't allowed to have fun.
And so I wondered:
Where is the line between just being honest and being mean?
Is it the intention of the person?
Because a guest once said to me:
Yo, did you poke before I saw you yesterday? Your pussy stank of poo.
And that is by far the meanest thing anyone has ever said to me in my entire life.
Especially because he knew that I had problems getting people close to my vagina.
I mean, it just felt weird, and it's fragile and scary
So I was: why would you say something like that to me ?!
And he honestly thought he wasn't mean.
He thought he was honest and sincere and that I would appreciate that.
What? I'm just being honest, right? Isn't that what people do when they are in love?
No, we all have stupid, terrible thoughts. Every day.
but that doesn't mean we should express them all?
I mean every time I have a knife in my hands I think:
Wow, I could just go completely free and stab everyone
And what could they do about it?
I could knock them all down
I mean, I'm not going to do it because I love them ..
but it could just be. Their lives are in my hands,
I could just stab and cut and kill them all. Hm ...
But I'm not going to "be honest" and tell all people right away.
Guys, isn't it strange that I could kill you all now?
I mean, is it possible? None of you have a weapon.
I could just sprint to you, Mary, and cut your throat open.
And put you in your heart, Jenny. And then just pick it up at Caitlyn, and then cut off Melissa's face.
* laughs *
and what would you do?
You would just die.
Maybe people just use honesty as an excuse to be a bastard.
and I'm certainly guilty of that
I did that anyway
but I really want to stop that
I don't want to hurt anyone's feelings just because I think I have the right to be honest with them.
and vice versa, if people are honest with me, hope it is for a good intention.
For example, that I date a violent person, or that I might become an alcoholic?
I don't want anyone telling me that, in their opinion, I did something wrong.
because my vagina didn't smell bad. And even if that were true, God commands, you should never say anything like that to me.
So I encourage you to think about all the times that you were honest
and then ask yourself: wasn't I just mean?
Are you ever honest when it's hard?
For example, when you need to tell someone that they may not want to hear and you don't want to say?
And not something that you simply don't like.
I'm Anna Akana, stay awesome Gotham!
And also a Shout out to Kelly for playing in my video!
You can watch her channel here, she uploads every day and is an ambassador for Hawaii.
Thank you, Kelly!
I want to thank Squarespace for making the video of today possible
Squarespace has a lot of beautiful, prize-winning templates.
and they also have an 'all-in-one platform'
So you don't have to install anything, and there are no updates and upgrades. Ever.
They also have a customer service that is available 24 hours a day
So if you are on the way to your newest victim, for example
and you want to update your website to keep the police informed
but you have technical problems, Squarespace is there to help you.
Oh yes, and if you need a domain, they offer an easy, unique set-up experience. Really a breeze.
You can use Squarespace for any kind of website.
Whether you are an artist, a photographer, or a serial killer like me
* laughs disturbed *
Go to squarespace.com, start your free practice period, and don't forget to use the discount code '' anna '' for a 10% discount.Squarespace.